okay so throughout the week we've
covered a lot of trailers that were
shown exclusively at comic-con to those
in hall h this has included ant-man and
the wasp quantomania and the guardians
of the galaxy vol 3. so i thought i'd
close out the week by touching upon one
of the most elusive ones that hasn't
been leaked online in any large capacity
that is secret invasion which puts the
secret in secret the thriller is set to
debut on disney plus in 2023 and
throughout this video i want to talk
about what was shown in the teaser some
of the rumors surrounding the film and
also what we can expect to see in it
from the comics if you've enjoyed our
coverage this week then please hit the
thumbs up button and also don't forget
to subscribe for videos like this every
day without the way thank you for
clicking this now let's get into secret
invasion now the comic storyline itself
picked up in the aftermath of civil war
there's several preludes and lots of
setup to it but if you pick up the main
comic then you should be able to quickly
jump on board with what's going on
however if you just need a quick rundown
of the setup to it it basically involves
nick fury discovering that scrolls have
transformed themselves into notable
heroes of the marvel universe furionites
are planned by valentina allegra
dafontaine where he discovers that she's
planning to kill him so that she can get
access to highly restricted shield intel
fury kills her first and it's revealed
she's a scroll which makes him start to
suspect there's double agents amongst
them this could be something that they
tackle in the show itself especially
with val becoming a big name in the mcu
now either way fury ends up sending in
spider-woman to infiltrate shield and to
keep an eye on things for him now fury
went into hiding and slowly he started
to investigate the heroes and those who
he believed were secretly scrolls now
the mcu of course did a big twist and
that it turned the skrulls into good
guys during captain marvel we even saw
and far from home how fury trusted talos
enough to let him poses him on earth and
it's gonna be interesting to see why
they've changed into enemies that want
to take over the planet my guess is that
there's a splinter cell within them and
that we'll watch scrolls on both sides
fighting alongside the humans and also
against them now in the comics shortly
after fury went into hiding tony stark
called together reed richards and hank
pym he brought out the body of an
electra scroll and we found out that
this had been brought in by spider woman
after civil war stark became the head of
shield and realizing that they'd been
infiltrated he started to put together a
plan to flush out the skrulls
spider woman told them that she
discovered a crashed scroll ship in the
savage land and the heroes headed out
there to tackle a threat head-on now
this led to a big fight in the area and
at one point tony was even convinced
that he himself was a skrull who had
been hypnotized in thinking that he was
the real stark several characters were
revealed as being the shape-shifters
including hank pym jarvis mockingbird
dum-dum duggin and even spider-woman
herself she'd set the whole thing up and
i can't imagine that there'll be a
reveal like maria hill or someone of
that level actually being a scroll yeah
beyond just the one and far from home
now if you cast your mind back to the
ending of that film then you'll remember
that fury was out in space on a scroll
ship it seems like he's been out there
for a while now as the teaser opens with
him stepping off an alien vessel i have
a theory time that ever since the events
of winter soldier that he's actually
been off earth as we get some strange
dialogue in the next scene on this both
fury and maria hill sit at the bar
together and they discuss how nick has
been avoiding earth for several years
who knows when he was lost on the planet
and potentially a body double scroll
could even explain how he was able to
get shot and win to soldier and still
come back the person who reached out to
captain marvel at the end of infinity
war could also be talos as he knew her
too and it would just flip everything on
its head if that was revealed to be the
case let me know your thoughts below on
when you think he dipped out but it
seems highly unlikely now that he
actually went to stark's funeral and
this was probably talos he touched upon
this and far from home when discussing
the edith glasses and fury has been
lying low for quite some time hill says
that she's called him several times for
help but that he's been quite content to
let those chords go to voicemail you see
kids you don't ghost nick fury nick fury
ghosts you see you chump now because of
this the conversation moves to how
something very important must be
happening on earth for him to return you
watch nick fury sitting with rhodey and
he says how much do you know about your
security detail there are lots of
theories online that rowdy might
actually be a scroll and that this might
retroactively be used as a way to
explain away the recast all the way back
in iron man 2. would be wild if he'd
just been a scroll this entire time and
at comic-con we learned that a faction
of scrolls had been infiltrating earth
for years and years this possibly goes
all the way back to the 90s and who
knows which characters they are now we
then hear the voice of talos at this
point and he says you've got to be very
careful fury we see that he looks the
same as the shield director from captain
marvel and he then stands up in a
boardroom and we watches others join him
it seems like these are all scrolls too
and talos may have infiltrated the group
himself now we also meet a person that
appears to be fury's boss we don't know
who this character is but she's played
by olivia coleman and she could
potentially also be a scroll too she
says you're in no shape for this fight
that lies before us and we get several
action shots it's clear that this is a
political thriller with a lot of the
battles and fights being very grounded
there's swat team members office blocks
expansive hallways and it all appears to
be taking place on earth we then hear
fury say this is my war alone and i'm
the last person standing between them
and what they really want the teaser
ends with talos asking and what is that
before we cut to black so really
exciting trailer and who knows who is a
scroll at this point fury might be one i
might be one you might bloody b1 come
here get him get him
now from what i saw i mean what my uncle
saw i'm sick of doing that joke what my
uncle saw he couldn't spot emilia
clark's character in the teaser though
it was filming half the screen either
way she's going to be playing a big role
in the movie and your boy is about to
drop a spoiler alert for who she may
potentially be this comes from daniel
rpk who brought us the scoop a while
back and it could hint to where this
show is gonna be going because of that
i'm giving you five seconds to exit the
video if you don't wanna know
five four three two one bruce willis was
dead the whole time you punk i gotcha
chump
anyway emilia clarke is apparently
playing a scroll known as gaia this is a
character that pulls from the comics and
along with her fellow scroll agent cler
the pair moved to earth so that they
could spy on us also gonna be
pronouncing all these names wrong now
together they acted as your typical
american family and they raised three
daughters together they were out hiding
on earth in order to prepare us for the
future skrill invasion however things
took a turn for the worse with the
family their daughter ivy was taken by a
group named project blossom who secretly
sought out undercover scroll agents ivy
was thought to have been killed though
this later turned out to be untrue the
pair continued their mission in her
absence and they also attempted to
uncover project blossom both she and her
husband posed as peppa potts in tony
stark and together they stole a lot of
information for the skrulls on the group
it became paramount that they took out
the members of blossom so that their
overall plan couldn't be uncovered and
there is potential that this might even
get pulled across to the show too now
what i love about this series is that it
has the potential to really flip the mc
on its head in the same way that loki
did everyone could be a skrull including
my uncle which would explain how he got
into all age to film the trailer and
also why he looks exactly like kevin
feige i really hope they make it as well
as the comics is as that has several big
characters that are revealed to be
scrolls which leads to some massive
ocean moments although this feels like
it could be being set up as the final
appearance of fury we know the marvel's
is gonna feature him as well that's the
problem with releasing your entire slate
for the next three years we already know
who lives and who dies and that debuts
after secret invasion so spoiler alert
he's gonna make it out but i am
interested to see how they tie this into
the end of one division i had maria
rambo who was recruited by a member of
the scrolls and this scene clearly
showed that they'd infiltrated it too
how it connects to that will probably be
explored in the series and i am quite
hyped to see how it all ties together
now it's a long ways away but in the
meantime i'd love to hear your thoughts
on the show and what you'd like to see
in it we're in a competition right now
giving away three copies of doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness on
the 15th of august and all you have to
do to be when the chance of winning is
like the video make sure you subscribe
with notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the leak you
pick the comments at random at the end
of the month and the winners of the last
one on screen right now so if that's you
message me on twitter heavyspoilers if
you want something else to watch make
sure you check out our breakdown of the
guardians trailer which will be linked
on screen right now we go over all the
big moments in it where they could be
heading and the new characters so
definitely head over there right after
this if not thanks for sticking to this
video hope you enjoy your weekend you
take care of yourself peace